good morning John so strangely enough
and I don't know if you've heard about
this I got a cancer it was and this
isn't a super close race the worst thing
that's ever happened to my body if I
hadn't gotten treatment for it I
wouldn't be dead yet but I'd be on my
way to dying luckily though for me there
was never any question about what we
were going to do about the cancer hodkin
lymphoma was one of the first cancers
that was shown to be really responsive
to both chemotherapy and radiation so
even though chemotherapy sucks I knew we
were going to do that chemotherapy
targets cancer cells really specifically
but not so specifically that it doesn't
Al get a bunch of the good guys but I
was 100% on board with chemo and it's
definitely extended my life it's
probably saved my life and I'll die of
some other thing and three out of the
four chemo drugs that I was on are
natural they're from nature Vin blasting
comes from the Madagascar Periwinkle
it's just in a cute little flower it was
known to the indigenous people in
Madagascar scientists checked it out and
found that it had a bunch of anti-cancer
properties another one Adria also called
docar rubison was found in microbes in
the soil at the the base of an Italian
Castle the third bomy was also found in
a soil microb called streptomyces
verticillus soil microbes have been
known for centuries to have
antibacterial properties people would
pack wounds with specific soils because
they knew that those soils would prevent
infection they didn't know why but they
knew that they would and the reason why
is that a lot of bacteria produce
antibiotic compounds to compete with
other bacteria and it turns out a lot of
antibiotics are also good chemotherapies
because they work by messing with cell's
ability to replicate themselves septes
verticillus was never used in
traditional medicine as far as we know
but all three of these molecules are
both natural compounds and very
effective chemotherapies for hodkin
lymphoma and some of them for other
things and they've been tested not just
to see if they're effective but what
doses are most effective which cancers
they are most effective against how
dangerous they are what side effects are
most common how they affect women versus
men how they affect people based on
their age their efficacy at different
stages of cancer how long you can safely
take them which side effects are most
serious and how to minimize those
complications both in the shortterm and
the long term because when we're talking
about chemotherapy side effects we're
not just talking about puking this week
which is a big deal but we're also
talking about long-term potential damage
like lung scarring or cardiac effects or
secondary cancers cancers are not chill
treatments usually have to be high
impact because these are high impact and
sneaky diseases and so it's kind of
amazing that we are in this point in
history where a lot of these medicines
have been tested in a lot of different
ways to see what their best dosing
schedule is to see how little you can
take without increasing the chances that
the cancer will come back to know how to
be prepared for potential side effects
this is the slow careful tedious work of
medical research and it made the cancer
treatment that I've been through way
less awful than it would have been just
10 years ago during the time when I was
publicly living with cancer and talking
about cancer treatment I received almost
universally Good Vibes like I just want
to be clear about that people were
amazing but I did get some folks who
would come to me and say that I would
have a better outcome and be healthier
if I took a more natural route by which
they meant that I should not be doing
chemotherapy there was Al a second set
of things that happened which is that
people would take my words and then they
would move them over into their social
media feeds in some way so they wouldn't
be talking directly to me they would be
talking about me and those people were a
lot less polite those people were
creating content around me about how my
decisions were bad and about how you
should do something different if you
ever have cancer or if you currently
have cancer I know that the right thing
to do is to not let the anger that I
felt about that show and how I talk
about those people so I'm trying to do
that but the question becomes
if most of my cancer treatments came
from nature what do they mean when they
say that I should be doing more natural
treatments I got to be clear here too
when it comes to like Epsom salt baths
and acupuncture during chemotherapy yes
I'm in favor of all of that if you want
to do it and your doctor is telling you
it's not going to do any harm and you
feel like it's going to do good do it I
took epom salt baths I don't know if it
was any good but it was like a chance to
take a big long bath and feel like I was
doing something for myself and there are
also supplements that we know don't hurt
and we think might help like I took fish
oil I took vitamin D I took magnesium
especially the Magnesium I think helps I
was getting muscle cramps that cleared
up after I took magnesium supplements as
long as you're talking to your doctor
about it and it doesn't look there's
negative consequences I say do it there
are some things that look like they
might have some positive effect but
nothing has a positive effect like
actual cancer treatment so skipping
those actual cancer treatments in favor
of natural treatment makes me wonder
what do you mean by natural and here it
is and I'm not sure sugar coding this I
don't know a nicer way to say it when we
say natural cancer treatment what we
mean is something that either we don't
know it works or we know that it doesn't
work or that we know that it does more
harm than good those that's the only
things that we mean when we say natural
cancer treatment because otherwise a
natural cancer treatment would include
the three compounds from nature that I
put in my body to cure my cancer the
majority of cancer cases on Earth and an
even greater majority of cancer deaths
on Earth happen outside of high-income
countries those people don't die of
cancers because they don't have access
to Coffee enemas or cannabis oil or
apricot pits they die because they don't
have access to chemotherapy radiation
surgery and screening it's just
obviously true it's just not something
that I think people who talk about
natural cancer treatment and avoiding
chemotherapy think about ever while I
was feeling like garbage while on chemo
I designed a bunch of socks and then my
friends picked the top eight that they
liked the most it was one of the only
things I felt like I was capable of
doing creatively with my brain in the
state that it was in they're comfy and
cozy and stylish and fun patterns and
they all use the exact same color scheme
so if you want you can mix and match to
have a little fun and 100% of the profit
goes to increase access to cancer
treatment cancer treatment does often
suck absolutely and also I feel so lucky
to be alive in this time in this place
so that I can have access to it 10 years
ago my treatment would have sucked more
30 years before that it would have been
horrible and probably caused me lifetime
disability 30 years before that it would
not have existed and yet there are
people on the Earth right now for whom
that same reality of 80 years ago in the
US is their reality now we don't have to
live in a world like that and also we
don't have to live in a world with
boring socks where the profit goes to
some stranger somewhere these socks are
going to be available for a long time
but this is the last day for standard
shipping with guaranteed delivery by
Christmas Eve so if you want to buy them
for somebody else now is the time that's
also the case for everything else at
good. store and dftba.com for people in
the US International all bets are off if
your style or the size that want has
sold out you can sign up to get a
notification I suggest you do that I
actually went to the warehouse this week
and made a bunch of boxes and packed a
bunch of orders it was a good time John
I'll see you on Tuesday